all right
so in the you need to know how to take
the Yan energy internalize it and go
down with
it um let's think about it for a little
bit this is more like an element of
CQ C is that once the energy comes in
then as it bouncing off the ground and
coming back and coming back up my body
okay that completes
CQ but I have to be able to stop taking
a
external uh
mechanical or a bracing
angle to make him look like he can't
push me over so my goal is not to not be
pushed over okay it's just is not being
pushed over is
indicative of that process of his y
energy coming in and being reoriented
downward okay got it okay so uh it's not
going to make me all powerful or
anything like that in in and of itself
but it leads to martial viability or
greater martial viability later okay so
we start out with our simple drill here
um we're looking
on his energy coming in and going down
the back foot okay that so the line that
I described to you energy coming in
instead of having it Vector out or stay
here at my wrist I'm going to have it go
in and have it press down
onto the back foot okay the front foot
is irrelevant there okay you got it you
guys understand so uh nobody could tell
like really how you're hard you're
pushing so go ahead and give it
something okay and this is the front
foot is irrelevant to what's happening
and I'm not leaning in any kind of
positive way here to have that bracing
in he's just making my back foot go
deeper and deeper into the ground
okay
so the problem
is doesn't this look like it
you see that doesn't that look like it
but if you pay attention where does it
not look like it Sean see if you can
come up and point to it or Taylor if you
want to say where or
Tristan what do you see your weight is
on the front foot okay so my knee angle
my knee angle is even with my toes you
see that and then my back leg what's the
knee articulation there it's kind of
it's straight on the other one it's bent
do you see it's bent you guys see that
okay so what you want to do is as you're
training you're not your goal is not to
stop him from pushing you over your goal
is to ground the back foot ground the
back foot okay that's your goal it
doesn't matter what you're doing with
your hands okay so for
example uh you know you like oh I'm I'm
trying to do leverage things on his
hands it it doesn't matter you're you're
grounding the back foot you're just
grounding the back foot the hands aren't
relevant okay and in fact the posture go
ahead keep pushing the posture is not
relevant either once you understand
what's going on
okay but because the other one looks
similar and because you want to try to
stop him from pushing you over as as
opposed to use him to ground the back
foot it helps the beginner if you take
away things that allow you to confuse
the two for you so when I lift one
leg right you you you don't have the
bracing angle on the back leg because
you would fall
forward so you can also take away the
back leg
entirely you see so if I'm external he's
driving he's going to push you where you
have no basis
support when I went to one leg clearly
the base of support is not relevant here
it's not a matter of line gravity line
of gravity inside the base of support
nor there as I noted why why I was able
to change my posture you see it's not
relevant to it but
here I don't have that foot there to use
but it's not as hard as one foot you see
so he's pushing and I'm just grounding
at same he's making both feet heavy and
again don't try to find leverage or
anything you're just here grounding
grounding okay and again if he lets go
really fast I don't go flying forward
because I wasn't doing this stuff you
see he lets go really fast and that's
not what I was doing
okay so let's try with two legs cuz one
front foot back foot it's too
easy to deceive ourselves with okay so
two legs out no possible bracing angle
okay let's try